yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
today I'm explaining everything you need
to know about happy deathday to you
including hidden details you missed in
that post-credit scene what the ending
really means the final baby face reveal
and how the finale sets up the third
movie in the franchise okay let's get
into it
now the timeline for this movie is
pretty complicated and there's a bunch
of subplots we need to break down to
completely understand what's going on
with the multiple dimensions and
doppelgangers that show up the sequel
kicks off with Carter's roommate Ryan
stuck in a time loop as he relives the
same day after getting murdered by
masked babyface killer what we soon
discovered though is that Ryan and a
couple of his fellow science students
have been working on a machine that's
supposed to slow down time on a
molecular level the city first quantum
cooling reactor or sissie as it's known
for short actually kicked off the time
loop in the original movie when the
machine started up unexpectedly a minute
after midnight on the 18th that's the
day that trees time loop began in the
first movie and something we also
discover is that whenever the machine is
turned on it causes brief power outages
which means it caused the blackouts we
saw in the first film tree Ryan and
Carter resolved to close the time loop
however there's the immediate problem of
the babyface killer stalking Ryan on
campus when babyface tries to kill Ryan
for a second time he gets knocked out by
tree and when she reveals his under the
mask they discover it's actually another
version of Ryan when he wakes up
Ryan's double explains that he was
trying to close the loop but somehow he
got knocked into a parallel timeline he
also warns them that they're all in
serious danger and that the longer they
all exist in the same dimension the
worse things will get Ryan's
doppelganger says that the butterfly
effect is at work and that the solution
is to kill the Ryan we know from this
world otherwise he'll create even bigger
problems
Ryan number one gets freaked out when he
realizes his doppelganger is deadly
serious about killing him so he ignores
everyone and tries to turn [ __ ] back on
to fix the problem as the machine powers
up it generates a huge pulse and shock
wave that sends everyone flying the
scene cuts to tree waking up again in
Carter's dorm room and she discovers
it's the xviii again and she's stuck in
a new time loop but this time tree has
been sent to an alternate dimension
let's call it earth too
well there it's a different world
there's still a babyface killer at large
on the University campus and tree dies
for the first time in the sequel when
she accidentally runs off the hospital
roof fleeing the masked murderer when
tree wakes up again to find it's the
18th she realizes a new time loop is in
effect and she starts working with
Ryan's team to figure out how to close
it tree needs to go through the time
loop each day and memorize the different
algorithms that Ryan's crew were testing
to fix [ __ ] and that's when we get the
amusing montage of tree deciding how she
should die each day rather than die at
the hands of babyface after more loops
tree and Ryan's team figure out the
algorithm they need to get [ __ ] working
again and tree also decides she wants to
go back to her own world
more on why she made that decision later
but before she leaves tree realizes she
still wants to deal with earth twos baby
face so she goes to the hospital where
although she manages to stop tombs from
murdering Lorri babyface then shows up
to reveal himself as dr. Gregory Gregory
had been setting tombs free so that
Lori's murder would cover up his affair
with her fun fact this reveal of
Gregory's baby face is a reference to
the original script of the first happy
deathday movie where Gregory and Lori
were both working as the original
baby-faced killers who were trying to
kill tree back in the sequel we discover
that Gregory's wife Stephanie is also in
on the murderous plan which was hinted
at earlier when she was having an
argument about a sorority girl with her
husband
Stephanie shoots Laurie but there's
another twist as Gregory turns the gun
on his wife shoots her and quips he
wanted a divorce Gregory and tree end up
in an MRI examination room where tree
turns the tables on the wicked doctor
when she switches on the machines
magnets and a metal wheelchair flies
towards it pinning Gregory to the
scanner then tree releases the
screwdriver she's holding which the
magnet Yanks towards the doctor stabbing
him dead in the chest making Gregory's
wife a villain in the sequel there's
also a neat little Easter Egg to the
alternate ending for happy death day one
in this deleted ending for the first
movie which wasn't used as it tested
terribly during test screenings the
final scene has tree at the hospital
again recovering from her injuries but
then Stephanie turns up and she murders
tree in revenge for their first she was
happy with Gregory
as for Laurie's role in the sequel well
this timer
she survives to the end of the movie
thanks to tree saving herb which is a
nice inversion at the end of the first
film where tree killed Laurie after she
discovered Laurie was the one trying to
kill her
now that babyface has been dealt with
it's time for tree to be sent back to
our own world but Assissi powers backer
tree shares a final kiss with carter
from earth to proving perhaps that even
between dimensions these two have a real
connection
although Carter was in a relationship
with Danielle on earth - the way he acts
around tree reveals his true feelings
for her
so tree is back in her world and the
credits roll but we also get a bonus
credit scene that sets up the next movie
as punishment for continuing to run
[ __ ] and defiance of the Dean's
commands tree Carter Ryan grey and Samar
have been ordered to clean up litter on
the University campus a team of
government agents then roll up out of
the blue led by a dr. Isaac Parker who
asked them to come with him and answer
some questions they're taken to a DARPA
facility which for anyone who doesn't
know is a real-life US Defense Agency
DARPA has taken possession of [ __ ] but
they can't figure out how to work the
machine ryan explains that there are
many algorithms and they need the right
one to make it work and tree points out
that she can help them with that
remember she did go through all those
time loops when she was on earth - and
memorized the various algorithms until
Ryan got [ __ ] working in that dimension
again dr. Parker then says they'll need
a test subject and tree wicked Lee says
she thinks she has the perfect recruit
the screen cuts to a shot of Danielle
waking up in bed screaming a clear
indication that Danielle is going to be
sent into a new time loop in the next
movie
both the Danielle's we've met on earth 1
& 2 are pretty terrible people earth 1
danielle is rude offensive and only
really cares about her state as a
sorority Queen B who's going to pledge
Kappa now that we've a death curse we're
in crisis mode 3 you know these people
call me as soon as you're done with your
creepy little comic-con meeting -
Danielle was slightly nicer and less
offensive but more of a fake and still
very pretentious and self-absorbed and
was possibly going out with Carter so
that he helped her pass one of her
courses plus of course tree discovered
her cheating on Carter with Nick also in
this credit scene as a sneaky little
detail about Samar which opens up
another plot point to explore and happy
deathday 3 while he's picking up litter
in the credits scene he finds an old
discarded Torah on the floor and says
who throws away a perfectly good churro
he then proceeds to eat it which is out
of character with the somali mess at the
beginning of the movie in the scene
where he brought Ryan a Torah from the
cafeteria Samar accidentally dropped it
on the floor and then made a big point
about how the churro had gone to waste
now because it was covered in bacteria
so why is Samar more than happy now in
the credits scene to eat a churro that's
been on the floor for at least a day
probably the answer is that I think this
isn't our original Samar it's a
different version of him from another
dimension
when tree was sent back to earth warm
from Earth - it's possible that the
original Samar on earth warm was
replaced by Samar from earth to earth to
Samar wouldn't necessarily have noticed
any difference yet as just like on earth
to his surroundings and the other people
would be similar and then the
possibility is that when tree was sent
back to earth Wanek course some other
ripple effect in one of the other
dimensions of the multiverse sending
over a different Samar doppelganger to
earth one remember that when Ryan from
earth 2 is explaining to tree about the
multiverse he says that the earth -
version of tree must have been knocked
into another parallel dimensions
somewhere in the multiverse and that in
theory the universe has six dimensions
so this stale churro munching version of
Samar could have been knocked out of
another dimension and into trees world
this leads me back to Ryan's
doppelganger who he met right at the
beginning of the movie and whose reasons
for ending up on earth one haven't been
fully explained yet in the franchise we
do get a little clue as to what's going
on here though it's just a little
comment that's made when earth to [ __ ]
is being fired up for the first time
Carter's concerned about the amount of
noise machines making and they tell him
not to worry as a machine won't blow up
again now that's a crucial little detail
that the movie doesn't linger on and the
exact timing of when [ __ ]
previously blew up isn't totally clear
but it seems like the [ __ ] machine on
earth-2 had a major meltdown at some
point before or around the moment when
[ __ ] went wrong on earth one which was
at one minute past midnight on the 18th
did that [ __ ] event on earth to trigger
a Fault in the multiverse that sent a
version of Ryan from another dimension
over to earth one by accident
Ryan's doppelganger at the beginning of
this movie kept saying he was trying to
close the loop and that he needs to kill
Ryan from earth one to stop him turning
on the machine and creating more
problems so did Ryan ones machine trick
of problems like a butterfly effect in
the rest of the multiverse including us
- what at earth twos machine fail first
there's clearly some event that's
happened that hopefully the happy
deathday filmmakers plan to address in
the next movie some other unanswered
questions about Ryan include what was
that distortion that Ryan one hears on
his phone each time he's in the time
loop and where was the call coming from
and what made earth one [ __ ] turn
itself on around midnight at a time when
the lab was locked
did the [ __ ] explosion that happened on
earth to riffle out into the other
dimensions or is there another [ __ ] and
another dimension going wrong and
kicking off a chain of events in the
multiverse whatever the answers are it
looks like happy death day three will
entangle us even further in a wider web
of parallel dimensions and alternate
timelines and I'd love to hear any of
your thoughts or theories you've got in
the comments below
although happy deathday to you is more
complicated than the original movie I
like the way that the universe has
expanded without the sequel playing like
a repeat of the first one you might be a
little disappointed if you're looking
for more of the horror elements in the
first film but the real star of happy
deathday has always been Jessica Ross
performance as tree and the sequel gives
her an opportunity to show the still
room for the original mean girl to grow
as a character although tree really
wants to live what she thinks is a
better version of her life were her
mum's alive she eventually comes to
realize that she needs to embrace the
real version of herself even if that
includes the pain that comes with it
writer director Christopher Landon has
said the Lessman theme of the movie is
that even if there are things in your
life that you regret or things have hurt
you it's still your life you have to
take ownership of it and so you can't
live in a fantasy version of your life
because it's not you on top of that when
tree sees on the local news that Carter
Laurie and the police officer have been
killed at the Haas
she refuses to be the final girl and
resets her own day in order to save her
friends proving that she's a worthy
heroine now I'd love to know what you
think of the sequel tap in the top right
to vote and leave any comments below and
if you enjoyed this video a thumbs up
and share are hugely appreciated thanks
for watching and see you next time you
became review lovers